one of one of the messages in the film
appears to be about trust which is
something that all of us can probably
say we struggle with how did that play
out in this you know changing of your
whole life view from going into the sort
of the mind to the heart and also how
did that transcend when making the film
well I had to really learn to trust much
more deeply because my life experience
having endure prolonged sexual abuse as
a child is all about there there was
nothing I could trust I couldn't even
trust myself to respond in a certain way
and so I had a completely let go of what
i thought this film is going to be about
over and over and over again and just
keep going with it and shake things up
when I got to be sort of you know what
what anticipating what I thought needed
to happen I'd had to do things like jump
out of a plane and say I mean I've gotta
trust as I say in the film that the
parachutes going to open that the pilot
is going to be able to fly the plane and
so trusting is the hardest thing for any
of us I don't care what your background
is about but trusting the unknown
because it was that certain trajectory
or so I thought of financial success and
going off into the sunset of retirement
vs I don't know what's going to happen
next but I was as long as I kept
trusting that left room for things the
unexpected miraculous things to happen
is they have over and over in this film
you mentioned that from an early age you
had what's called clairaudience and you
tell us what that is well it's it's the
faculty we tend to call it a higher mind
faculty but it's all an intuitive
faculties where I could hear things that
I learned as I grew up that other people
weren't hearing so I I thought everybody
had this and so I would hear things or I
would know things clairsentience and
there's actually six higher brain
functions which include taste and touch
and smell but I had i could hear things
i'll in learn to hide it because if i
said oh by the way so and so is about to
pass away it would scare everybody so i
was told don't do that so I shut that
down for a while until
um all this job loss that happened and I
said well I think this is part of what
I'm here to do is to share this
intuitive knowing that I have with the
with more people that didn't fit in in
the world of finance and banking that's
for sure
you